salut et bienvenue dans une nouvelle
vidéo casse tête avec verrou 55 son vrai
nom c'est schloss 55 ça doit vouloir
dire vers où je suppose en allemand ça
commence bien
durant les quatre prochaines semaines je
serai pas vraiment en vacances parce que
je prépare d'autres choses mais je vais
faire une petite pause youtube mais
attention les vidéos sortiront quand
même une fois par semaine tous les
mercredis à six heures ça ça change pas
et ce sera quatre semaines deux
casse-tête
les amateurs de caste et se régale si
vous n'aimez pas les casse-têtes
promener au mois de septembre du groupe
sachant qu'ils restent quand même pas
mal de vidéos à revoir sur la chaîne si
vous voulez vous avez été nombreuses et
nombreux à me demander dans les
commentaires des casse tête de matt un
timer ou de voir des versions non coupé
sachez que tous les cas peut-être que je
vais faire donc celui ci et les quatre
prochaines semaines
je mettrai les versions non montée de la
résolution sur ma chaîne secondaire que
vous avez dans la description c'est
parti je commence par vous lire un peu
la description c'est un verrou en bois
créée par jean claude constantin
fabriqués en allemagne difficultés
extrêmes temps de résolution moyen entre
30 minutes et trente jours
j'espère qu'on fera pas 30 jours quand
tu as 30 jours de carte sd ou pas pas
tant en guerre non mais je me not
objectif ouvrir le verrou en bois ok
donc on est parti dessus loïc petits
plans badass de présentation casse tête
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme d'habitude on va commencer par
étudier ce casse tête là il ya ça qui
est tombé là tout à l'heure mais je
pense que c'est juste que je fais pour
bloquer pour bloquer les rondelles qui
doivent pouvoir bouger on va étudier ça
là c'est fermer ici donc objectif
l'ouvrir hockey et donc ça ce ne sont
pas les mêmes raccord entre ici ok et
les petites grilles marque les positions
de départ mais on comprend assez
facilement la rondelle qui est de ce
côté ne ressort pas de ce côté de la
rondelle qui ressort de ce côté ne
ressortent pas de ce côté donc l ont pas
les mêmes mouvements et j'ai un
mouvement enfin une case vide qui va me
permettre de faire bouger un petit peu
l'ensemble
pour après pouvoir ouvrir ça comme ça
j'imagine donc qu'est ce qui l'empêché
d'ouvrir je sais pas tellement encore je
vais tout déplacer un peu pour voir ce
qui se cache un peu derrière pour voir
comment on commet il est foutu
ah oui d'accord ok
je vais le manipuler comme ça comme ça
vous vous verrez bien aussi c'est à dire
je vous fait voir à cette caméra là je
vais essayer de manipuler ceux de
derrière directement avec mes doigts
comme ça et ceux de devant
vous verrez pas forcément ce que font
mes doigts directement derrière l'as
déjà en déplaçant celui qui est devant
ça me permettait de retenir c'est lui
qui est derrière ces jeux pas qu'il
descend on va se le faire comme ça
donc là on a quoi on a une grande fête
ici donc il se retirera avec le canada
et j'ai envie de voir un peu ce qu'il ya
de ce côté là derrière du coup ah oui ah
oui lui je pourrais jamais le faire
descendre en fait il sera toujours sur
cette ligne-là du coup je vous devez ses
dollars
voilà et du coup lui peut que le faire
du haut bas donc là je vais faire ça
comme ça toute cette partie là en bois
avec la fonte et bien relié à tout le
reste de la planche ici il ya une
encoche là et une encoche là
vous voyez cet homme coche au dessus de
mon trou s'est laissé tant qu'homme je
suis mon index
pour moi ça veut dire qu'il va s'ouvrir
en fait dans ce sens là et qui va il va
y avoir une rotation ce qui est assez
logique puisque là c'est plein et qu'ici
on voit qu'ils aient une séparation on
assure le bois le bois très foncé donc
il va falloir l'ouvrir comme ça donc ça
veut dire que trois vont gêner et que
potentiellement lui aussi l'air ok avoir
l'idée est donc de d'ouvrir sa d'un sens
là qu'est ce qui bloque et çà çà çà çà
bouge de où ça mesdames et messieurs ça
bouge dans tous les sens je me demande
s'il ya pas un truc à faire aussi avec
ça est ce que tu vis en boîte quelque
part en fait quand il ya des petits
filetage à l'intérieur je me demande si
c'est si c'est voulu ou pas d'accord il
ya un mandat et regarder ne cherche pas
pour rien moi s'il ya des éléments parce
que des fois y'a quoi il ya des aimants
donc il ya un aimant ici là il y en a
pas là il y en a pas et là il y en a un
aussi
ça veut dire quoi jean-jacques que ce
fait leur retour ça veut dire que déjà
là c'est une vi et là pas du tout et
s'il ya deux aimants c'est qu'on cherche
à retenir quelque chose donc quelque
chose de potentiellement ah oui les deux
côtés potentiellement amovible ok donc
ces deux côtés là sans lever et ça c'est
le petit aimant qui avait dessus dans ce
cas que nous - servent à autre chose
ça c'est le même filetage les trois
hockey et là on commence à avoir un
petit peu de rotations si vous voyez
bien là ici là vous voyez que sous mon
pouce et un petit jeu qui se fait là ils
demandent à être ouvert la théorie de
départ qui coup quand je disais que là
il y avait un axe que c'était plein et
que ça allait s'ouvrir comme ça allez
bonne et là je vois ce qui bloque ce
qu'il empêche d'ouvrir ce sont tous ces
trucs là qui dépasse et sûrement lui
aussi donc baisser parti il faut
déplacer tout ça je vais déjà essayé de
virer lice pour voir voilà du coup lui
en fait faudrait de l'année tout en bas
comment je peux faire
bon là je suis obligé de passer comme ça
mais une fois que je suis là là je dis
pas ça y est ça qui avait dit pérol
obligent peut pas le déplacer là il va
que dans le sens vertical pas
horizontale donc qui ça va être vraiment
atteint mon départ c'est lui je le
dessin ça ne sert à rien il faudrait que
je décale lui d'abord voulu me d'abord
pour décaler lui d'abord eh ben on ne
peut pas le dessein de [ __ ] évidemment
fabien ce que j ce faire ça et si je
fais ça je me bloque pour l'instant le
trajet là je me bloque
non je peux faire ça lalala lalala métro
bien dans ton petit axe toi ce que tu
fais merci allait tomber correctement
mais là c'est pareil ça ne change rien
non peut-être vaut mieux quand même que
je parle de lui pour le faire descendre
comme ça voilà ok ça c'est une bonne
idée
oui je me parle à moi même les gars je
sais même que vous étiez goûteuse lui je
peux le descendre là comme ça pourquoi
je vais descend là parce que comme ça je
me dis que là maintenant je peux
attaquer celui-là est celui-là si je
fais un truc un peu comme à ce qui s'est
mal me [ __ ] ça s'est un peu relou
attaque comme ça je peux monter lui du
coup m lui ici est encore descendu d'un
cran
vous avez vu lui il était là au départ
et en fait là mon objectif c'est de
descendre de plus en plus sauf qu'en
mettant là je bloque le game parce que
lui je peux pas le descendre et lui là
je peux pas le l'emmener à gauche ok
parce que je trouve que l'idée était
bonne en soi on va partir sur un petit
accéléré mesdames et messieurs loïc
accélération
[Musique]
et je vais avoir un gros bug je me
concentre un peu trop à tort sur
celui-ci spécifiquement je me dis si
jeunes tous la barre et qui a qu'un trou
je pourrai jamais éjecter les quatre
dire si ce qui pousse par là et ceux qui
poussent par la gêne il ya forcément un
des deux qui gêne pas et par rapport à
comment est fait le casse tête je pense
que ceux du sud jeunes fera donc le seul
qui gênent réellement serait celui qui
sort de ce côté là du casse-tête là
celui là celui ci c'est à dire qu'il
faut vraiment que je le mette en bas
puisque en bas on voit qu'il ya une
séparation que ça gêne pas et donc lui
il faut que j'arrive à le dégager et lui
elle décide si lui je vais le dégager
faut qu'ils partent par là le problème
c'est qu'en le faisant partir par là lui
je peux pas le descendre après donc oui
il faut que le descendre mais pour le
dessin il faut que j'avais par là et si
je suis là après je suis bloqué parce
que lui il peut pas aller là à lui peut
pas aller là donc il faudrait que lui à
la limite soit la place de lui parce que
ça c'est possible
ce qu'on peut en mettant à la place de
lui peut-être mais lui il faudrait qu'il
soit comme ça ça c'est pas possible non
plus ce que voulait le voir de très près
si vous voulez je vous fait voir de très
pratique wallah que ça donne de très
près le question est-ce qu'il faut
chercher à dégager lui a fait
redescendre l'ensemble où est-ce qu'il
faut essayer de les virer un pain pour
faire descendre ensemble
en clair est-ce que j'ai tout intérêt à
remettre ça où il était en haut pour
essayer de d'abord supprimer celui ci
c'est la question que je me pose
vous voyez plus du tout la question que
je me pose et du coup je vais essayer de
faire ça en accéléré
[Musique]
intéressante regarder parce que là le
trou maintenant est là mais là je peux
le passé comme ça c'est pas mal la gelée
descendu là et là il faudrait que
j'amène le trou comme ça
donc qu'est-ce que je agi lentement mon
fab me permettre moi là comme ça ici ok
tu as donc plus tard donc tact l'âge
l'emmener en bas est ce que ça
fonctionne
est ce qu'on entend la petite musique de
loïc oui ça fonctionne extrêmement bien
et on est sur une ouverture de castets
loïc donc la théorie était bonne c'était
bien lui qui bloquaient en bas et eux ne
bloque rien puisqu'ils sont posés dessus
en fait la double épaisseur et devenait
de st vous voyez cette caméra la cool
loïc est ce que tu pense qu'il faut que
je repasse s'amuse à 0 moi je fais pas
pour l'offrir qu'ils soient dans sa
position de départ tels que je les reçus
cool tellement respectueux disent non
comme vous le savez je mettrais ce casse
tête à gagner sur instagram comme
d'habitude vous chercher cette photo ici
celle qui est juste là voilà et je vais
la posté aujourd'hui et dessus vous
faites c'est de marquer pour participer
au concours et après comme d'habitude je
vous l'envoie chez vous à votre domicile
en fait ce qui est intéressant c'est de
se dire que le hausse ne servait pas à
rien genre pas du tout il servait pas du
tout arrive je vraiment au départ
j'aurais juré que ces deux là on s'en
foutait un peu énorme isde est vraiment
nécessaire à manipuler au client en août
par contre quand tu as compris la
logique ses mains puis mes deux j'ai
parlé un peu trop vite parce que là du
coup je bloque
[Musique]
des petites marques sur sur le pire est
que cela donc j'essaye de bien mettre
les embouts dedans c'était ça le truc de
départ genre lui devrait être là et là
derrière on a la même chose hop là à
savoir des petits cercles noirs et donc
ils doivent tous aident d'un art cercle
noir
sachant que lui ça n'est pas un vrai un
seul sait le bloqueur et ben voilà
voici donc un casse tête qui a été
rondement menée pas simple pas si
difficile que ça j'ai pas passer la
journée dessus non plus mais très
agréable à faire je vous mets un lien
dans la description vers ce casse tête
comme d'habitude
n'oubliez pas sûrement instagram vous
pouvez le gagner en allant voir la photo
que j'ai posté aujourd'hui où est ce
qu'il y à ce casse-tête là durant tout
le mois d'août sur la chaîne vous aurez
donc des casse têtes en veux tu en voilà
avec comme pour celui ci c'est déjà le
cas
le même jour de cette publication au
même moment vous avez la version non
montée de toute la résolution avec des
fois des coups de téléphone des bugs des
lumières il ya tout dessus
n'hésitez pas à les voir ça moi je vous
dis à très bientôt ciao